[Music]
zachary is in atlanta hi zachary how are
you
better than i can
you know what i'm trying to say
that yeah i got it what's up
um so i have um
a couple things going on uh first i've
been i've been on
your plan for on the ramsey plan for for
quite a while i've gotten out of debt i
think twice been totaling over 28 000
dollars total
um that was all due to a workers comp
lump sum paying it off so i didn't
really like learning the lesson you know
um so
right now i'm in atlanta and i'm an
electrician um i do that and because
kovid's stuff it's been back and forth
on how much i'm making and things like
that because they're raising prices and
all that
i'm also a youth pastor
and i just it's basically
um
just on sundays and stuff like that
meeting with the youth and the lord's
been really good there
so i have about eight thousand dollars
left in this debt um and this grouping i
was at 18 a few months ago and then i
sold the truck
and that was hard to do but i sold it
and we got about 8k left
we got a baby on the way
and
i i'm having an issue getting
full going on the ramsey way
um because i didn't learn the lesson the
first time
um
and i think my issue is one i mean i
know i need to on the cutting the eating
out actually brought my lunch today
thanks to my wife um my biggest issue
that i'm having is with the envelope
system i'm not sure how to budget with
envelopes with money that i don't
already have in cash yet
and i'm kind of struggling with that
along with the i know i need to stop
eating out
i just want to get some advice on that
well let's just use uh a grocery store
envelope as an example
okay
when you go to the grocery store
if you're not borrowing money to buy the
groceries
you're either hitting your debit card
and taking out of your checking account
or you're taking out of your groceries
envelope agreed yeah the cash yeah yeah
so what would be wrong with taking the
money out of your checking account and
put it in cash in the grocery envelope
because it's him there would be an issue
with that it's in there well no so
here's yeah so at the end of the month
um i get paid bi-weekly and so at the
end of the month i have or the first of
the month have rent come in
so all the money i've saved up at the
first of the month okay i'm like all
right so i'm let's say the 30th of
september we're going to sit down and do
our budget be my wife
and we're going to want to put cash in
there well i'm not going to have any
cash to put in any of the then you're
not going to have money to buy groceries
in your checking account
until the church pays me on the fourth
of every month like they've been doing
and then
so my point is your system wait a minute
stop you're not going to buy groceries
for four days out of your checking
account is what you're saying
yeah would planned uh the two weeks
prior to get stuff before um well how
did you i mean that way the envelope is
not the problem the problem is you
didn't plan to have money for groceries
yeah if you've got money for groceries
in your checking account there's nothing
stopping you from keeping it out and
putting in the grocery envelope
okay i'm just processing okay
you see what i'm saying
you can't write a check or use your
debit card at the grocery store unless
there's money in your account agreed
yeah and if there's money in your
account you could take that exact same
amount out of your account and put it in
cash into an envelope set of groceries
on it couldn't you
yeah okay so you're not short of cash
unless you're short of cash
the envelopes don't change the equation
yeah
it's just when the just i guess it's
just when we're sitting down doing it on
the 30th i don't have any of the cash to
put in for the beginning of the month
till the fourth or then how are you
buying groceries between the first and
the fourth
now
i would have bought it a week or two
prior ta-da
so am i do you feel the envelope when
the next check comes in on the fourth
yeah because that's the way you're doing
it now
the only difference is you're writing
out your checking account yeah something
no i'm i'm hearing it so whatever that
next check is after the fourth that
needs to fund you through the next time
you get a paycheck
so you can divide it up if you want we
had been doing but god but you're having
issues with with doing it that way
uh with dividing it up yeah that's the
best way to say that yeah yeah just
divide it by two if you're getting two
checks a month and your grocery bill's
200 bucks you can put 100 in on one
check and 100 on the other if that gets
you through all right it's not going to
be that'd be more than that but the the
it's every two weeks so you've got to
look at the calendar
yeah because you don't get checks on the
first and the 15th you get a check on
every month on the fourth for your youth
pastoring and then you get a check every
two weeks so some weeks
twice a year you get three checks in a
month
that's true yeah because you have the
magic month when you get paid every two
weeks yeah
and so two times a year december this
year exactly
exactly so that that's the point and um
so what you gotta do is you sit down you
look at the calendar and you say this
month the month of september i'm gonna
get or the month of october now coming
up i'm going to get a check on x and y
and i'm going to get a check on the
fourth and then you allocate each one of
those checks across the things and oh by
the way the very most important category
of all is
food yeah the four corners of i've heard
you said before
exactly
exactly um and i had one more other
thing if i have the time for it
the uh so the wife is pregnant and it's
really hard to say no to a pregnant
woman who's hungry so do i need to set
us a separate budget for that to come
out of or do i just say look baby we
just gonna have to suck it up uh the
pregnant woman that's hungry has to say
no to herself because she's building a
life for her child
it's not your job to be her daddy
she looks in the mirror and says it's
good for my family for us to be on a
budget and stick to that budget and has
to agree to the budget you don't tell
her what the budget is the two of you
together agree to the budget and then
she will be saying no to herself because
she's like a grown-up woman and stuff
this is the ramsay show